foreign
it is one of America's most popular
endurance challenges each year more than
3 million people visit part of the
Appalachian Trail but only a fraction
about 3 000 people complete the entire
2200 mile mountainous Trek Janet shamlin
has the story of how a mother and
daughter were inspired to conquer that
roots
travel partner backed out of hiking the
Appalachian Trail her 66 year old mother
Susan stepped in the mom-ness in her
kicked in and she didn't want me to be
alone and she was a little bit scared
when you volunteered to go along with
your daughter did you have any idea
everything that was involved no totally
clueless I just like I know where Maine
is and I know where Georgia is and I
knew it was a long way but I had no idea
it was like climbing up and down
mountains the whole way was it ever this
cold on the trail
Yes actually both women are active
having on marathons and other races but
they say nothing prepares you for the
Appalachian Trail you have to develop
your Trail legs you can train all you
want before you get on trail but you're
not really training your body like you
do need to use your body on trail good
morning
States almost 2200 Miles when she
suggested hey I'll do it with you any
trepidation on you oh yes 100 she has
got to be the most accident-prone person
on this planet so I was worried for her
safety oh we made it to the ER and there
were mishaps mom fell and hit her head
again second fall what were your
injuries I got 10 Staples across the top
of my head and I mean stitches you're
kind of used to but Staples you know
that was weird so that was in rock
Sylvania rocksylvania is what they call
the state of Pennsylvania because there
is a very significant portion of the
trail that is made up of rocks but the
team resilient Go Mama the thought of
giving up never entered my head the trip
had a greater purpose fundraising for
Parkinson's in honor of Greta's father
and Susan's husband Ron who has the
disease I think part of it that really
helped with that was the bigger goal you
know finish the trail raise money for
Parkinson's research so without those
kind of it would have been pretty easy
to to give up and go home they've raised
eighty thousand dollars but but as
meaningful was what others did for them
what did you take away from this just
the kindness that is alive in humanity
people are so kind and we stayed in the
homes of 25 different people who we had
not met before doing the trial in our
world we just hear so much about the
negativity or the bad things that are
going on and the trail really opened our
eyes to the goodness that is alive and
we've heard the phrase if you want to
restore your faith in humanity go hike
the Appalachian Trail because boy oh boy
is that true it's such a great
experience I mean we feel so blessed to
have had the opportunity
and the joy of this reunion it Trails
End
the man in their heart every step of the
way
for CBS Saturday morning Janet shamlian
Minneapolis
that was so special I love every bit of
their story and what they learned and
they stayed in 25 different people's
homes I know who didn't even know them
have you ever backpacked over a period
of time with people it's it's that kind
of you meet people in that restorative
sense of humanity comes back to you they
just do you and I both have the both
eighty thousand that's a lot of money
raised a lot of money you're here good
for them